want to bring in fox news sunday host
chris wallace chris good morning to you
on a friday
16 days you have to really make a
comment about this
what do you think this indicates
about what this administration's
priorities are chris
well i i don't know about priorities but
it doesn't seem that they have much of
an answer
to the crisis at the border and maybe
that's the reason that they're not
they're not pushing it and and you know
it's so interesting because when the
president
first said that he was putting kamala
harris as vice president in charge of
the border
uh there was the sense was that he was
putting her in charge of the border the
whole
issue and then a day or so later the
clarification came well no she's not in
charge of the border
she's in charge of diplomacy uh with
mexico and with the northern triangle
countries to try to stem the flow
to the border uh she's had a couple of
phone calls with
top officials in those countries but she
hasn't gone
to the border and she hasn't gone to the
northern triangle and she hasn't gone to
mexico
which kind of makes you wonder whether
she knows this is a mess and doesn't
want her fingerprints on it
yeah i wonder if it's that or i wonder
also chris if they think that if her
going would just solidify in everybody's
mind
that it is the crisis that people have
been clamoring about not just a
challenge
well at a certain point you know i
suppose maybe a month or so ago dana you
could
play this game well it's not a crisis
it's a challenge but when you see
these videos that you have just shown of
the the kids being dropped from the wall
or that little boy deserted in the
desert
or more importantly the the tremendous
and terrible overcrowding of uh cbb
cbp facilities 20 000 people in federal
custody 172
border stops in the month of march
i i think we're way past the point where
you can uh even pretend that this isn't
a crisis at the border
it is it's a humanitarian crisis it's an
immigration national sovereignty crisis
there's no two ways around it the
question is what are you going to do
about it
and what are you going to do about this
uh here is joe biden in the rose garden
yesterday at the white house on some gun
proposals
that he's now putting forward give it a
listen
nothing nothing i'm about to recommend
in any way impinges on the second
amendment
they're phony arguments the idea is just
bizarre to suggest that some of the
things we're recommending
are contrary to the constitution gun
violence
in this country is an epidemic let me
say it again
gun violence in this country is an
epidemic
and it's an international embarrassment
a few proposals do you think they go
anywhere chris maybe that's the right
question now
well in terms of his executive orders
yeah they
those go into effect regulation of ghost
guns
uh calling on i mean they're not even
actually submitting legislation on red
flag
we would take away a gun from somebody
who's been adjudicated to be a danger
to themselves or others they're simply
saying to the justice department write
the legislation
so the executive orders are go as far as
they do
but they certainly aren't going to solve
this problem
you you know it is the second amendment
to the constitution the right to bear
arms
uh i think quite rightly you should have
to if you're going to
in any way limited have to do it through
legislation not through executive fiat
and the president just plain doesn't
have the votes i'm not sure he has 50
democratic votes but he certainly
doesn't have 10 republican votes to
break a filibuster with the 60-vote
margin so you know we've seen this
this movie before bill uh terrible
uh incidences of bloodshed just this
week in south carolina
and bryan texas uh everybody talking
about what can we do about it
uh a lot of huffing and puffing on all
sides of the issue and i think there's
good faith i think
on both the the side of more gun control
and the side of trying to protect our
second amendment
but there we'd never seem to be able to
solve the problem i don't
have any indication the movie is going
to end any differently this time
quickly on sunday go ahead what do you
have coming up this weekend
well we have the perfect guest to talk
about both guns and the border an
exclusive interview with the governor of
texas greg
abbott uh he's on the front lines on
both of these issues we'll also talk to
him
about covid because texas has taken an
interesting approach they have lifted a
lot of the mandates
on masks and limiting people coming in
they had a full house for the texas
rangers opening day and they're doing
pretty well
so maybe they know something we don't
we'll talk to the governor and then
infrastructure will be talking to the
secretary of transportation pete but a
judge what is infrastructure how do you
pay for it
and the number two republican in the
senate john thune who obviously has very
different views and all of that so a big
show
but our lead guest the governor of texas
on fox news hong kong
great lineup thank you chris thank you
chris